I'm Paul Pfefferli and I'm a scoutmaster with troop number 23 in Bluefield, New Jersey.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks, Paul.
And now to you, scoutmaster.
I hope you had as fine a summer as I did. you got to get out and do a lot of good
camping.
This is an observation that came to me this summer after being out camping for a while,
And that is that a nylon tent, or even a canvas tent, is not a soundproof booth
And scouts don't understand that.
Maybe we should let them know,
I don't know.
Hey, this is podcast number 325..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
It's good to be back.
We had a nice long break this summer
And I'm going to go straight to the mailbag, because we heard from a lot of folks while
we were away
And we'll be picking away at emails here for the next couple of three podcasts.
The first message comes from Vincent Cardin
And he's an assistant scoutmaster with Troop 900 in Prince George's, Virginia,
And he writes in to say: just finished our first summer camp at T Brady Saunders, right
here in the heart of Virginia Council.
My son is a tenderfoot- had an extraordinary time.
We've been working on his swimming prowess for over a year and a half to get him
ready for swimming merit badge requirements and he did great.
He completed all the requirements and we were ecstatic.
Seeing a wonderful and different part of my son during an after camp really gives me pause
to thank God for our great organization.
Thanks for what you do and keep up the great work.
Every scouter knows that feeling,
The accomplishment that you see in your scouts.
Here's hoping that's the first of many, many more.
Here's a review of my book
So far, so good on Amazon, a five star review by Jim Green.
No relation there.
Jim says it's a nice, quick story that along the way gives lessons on the how and
why of the patrol method and a youth led troop.
These are so timeless in construct that the book could have been written in any
era. but that's the point.
Scouts are learning to become adults and the tried and true methods work
if we let them.
Even if you think your troop is perfectly youth led, let this book test
your assumption and clarify your motivations.
Well, thanks so much, Jim.
I'm glad you enjoyed the book.
Once again, I'll take the opportunity to make a shameless self-promoting
plug, but the name of the book is So Far, So Good- A New Scoutmaster Story.
If you haven't heard of it, you can get a copy at Amazon.
I'll have a link in the podcast notes.
You can also get a audiobook version
And, if you're interested, you can become a backer and
get a special autographed version.
I'll talk more about that in a minute.
Heard from Bob Hughes, who's the scoutmaster of Troop Five at Scott
Air Force Base in Illinois,
And Bob and I exchanged a number of emails about High Adventure last
year and I heard for this from him recently.
We made it back from the Boundary Waters Canoe Area a few weeks ago.
The troops' first High Adventure trip in 15 plus years is behind us,
but the memories are forever.
It's amazing how easy it was to actually plan.
We covered over 40 miles and I wanted to drop a line before too much time
passed, and thank you for your encouragement.
Keep on encouraging other adults to change the world by encouraging our
youth
Well, thanks so much, Bob.
We had a great High Adventure trip up in Algonquin Park in Ontario, Canada, this year.
20 people in three crews went up for a week of canoeing.
High Adventure belongs on your scout calendar.
Every scout should have the opportunity to participate in a High Adventure trip like this.
We'll be back to having live chats here soon.
What you do is keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed, okay,
And I will put an announcement up when we're live at scoutmastercgcom.
You stop in, sign in to the chat, say hello,
And we have deep discussions about important things and
sometimes we just talk about the weather. so
But in our last live chat, which was quite a while back,
a lot of our frequent fliers checked in, as did Susan Benedict,
who's an assistant scout master in Missouri.
Watch our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed.
Come and join us in a live chat.
It's great fun.
Let me take a moment before I go any further, just to remind you if you're a regular
reader and listener and the resources we've created have helped you.
I want to take a moment and ask you to return the favor by supporting our work
financially.
There's two ways to do this.
You can make a one-time payment and become a scoutmastercgcom backer, or
you can make a monthly subscription payment of $5 or more via Patreon,
And there are special premiums available to anyone becomes a patron or a backer.
What you do is go to scoutmastercgcom, look up at the top of the page,
You'll see a link to become a patron.
You'll see a link to become a backer.
I'll also have those links in the podcast notes.
Check them out this week,
See what'll work for you.
And I would like to take a moment to personally thank Dean Roberts,
Paul Fefferly, Trisha Hackney, Mike Johnstone, Michael Laughlin
and John Swetowski, who've become backers since our last podcast,
And I also want to thank Mark Eshin, who's become a patron since our last podcast.
Take a little time this week, figure out what option works for you
and I'll be sure to thank you personally on next week's podcast.
Well, the rest of this week's podcast is going to be taking up answering email
questions.
A lot of them came in over the break and we'll get a good start on.
I've got three lined up and that's going to take up the remainder of the
podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
You were always on the beat boy, beat boy.
I'll hang it in the street boy, street boy.
We re-dancing to the beat boy, beat boy.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Often, because of the nature of the questions asked to me in
email, I withhold the names of the people who asked them, in
their locations and things,
And that's going to be true of this first question.
It came from a new scout master who's been a scout master
for about a year,
Had a behavior problem at summer camp recently,
something pretty serious
And I'm not going to go into details about exactly what it was,
but had a similar problem with the same scout at a previous
camp and had a conference with the scout
And the parent thought it worked out. after the most recent
incident
They took the position that the scout should probably be
removed from the troop.
The parent defended the actions of the scout and claims that
the troop didn't do enough to prevent the incident.
So they had to feel through this situation here-
not a very good one, very difficult situation.
Ultimately they got the chartered organization involved
and the chartered organization's decision was to remove
the scout from a troop.
And this scouter wrote in to ask me if I agreed with
the decision or if I've heard of anything similar.
And indeed I have, and I'm sorry to hear about that
kind of trouble-
And I haven't had to deal with the particular behavior
described in this email,
But I've dealt with bad behavior that results in
removing a scout from the troop.
It's a pretty traumatic thing to do
And it's a pretty traumatic thing to go through as a
scouter, and anybody who has to do that has my sympathies.
Now, this is not something that happens all the time.
It's not a regular occurrence.
In my 30 plus years as a scouter I can only recall
one incident that was serious enough to merit
having to do this.
And you know, no matter how ardently we believe in our
scouts and how hard we try and help them,
sometimes it's just not going to work
And thankfully that is a rare situation,
But it can really knock the wind out of you as a scouter.
Now I won't second guess the decision that was made
or the way it was made.
It sounds like everything was handled well in this
situation
And this kind of decision is ultimately the charter
organization's decision in consultation with the
troop committee, who's also talking with the
scout master and assistant scout masters.
Then you also involve the scout executive in this
particular thing,
And that's sometimes an important part of arriving at
a workable resolution.
My guess is, if you're like me, there's at least a
shadow of doubt in your mind whether you did the
right thing or not.
I think that would be true of most of the people
listening, because the point of our volunteering is
because we really believe in young people,
And when we have to take a step like this,
it's very discouraging
And I think there's a lot of second guessing involved,
if you're like me, especially if a parent
accuses you of not having done enough to
prevent what happened.
Whenever I bring up a behavior problem with a
parent, usually they react by defending their
child.
I kind of expect it, because I think that's the
same way I would react if I was confronted with
a problem that my child caused.
But what's really most important is that
scouting happens in an atmosphere of mutual
trust and brotherhood rather than a matrix
of rules and regulations.
The rational measures we take to protect our
scouts from harm can't prevent
every possible problem.
I've been through a lot of difficult situations,
and some still cause me some discomfort
when I think about them and I wonder if I
could have handled them better,
But I've come to understand that that discomfort
is evidence of the sensitivity
required of anybody who's going to spend
their time working with young people.
After I sent that reply, the writer got back
to me and said: thanks for your words of
encouragement and advice.
Your reply helps me tremendously to deal
with the second thoughts in my head after
going through this.
The most difficult part was some people in
the troop wanted to offer a provisional
membership to the scout if their parent
attended or something like that, and I
disagreed and we're still working that
out.
Well, I've heard the idea of allowing a
scout to continue on who's been a
behavior problem if their parent is
going to be present all the time,
But it's not going to work because
scouting doesn't work that way.
There's no way to have authentic scouting,
with a parent who is going to be
there, closely involved in the
oversight of a scout's behavior.
That sort of arrangement would
fundamentally change the experience
for all the scouts involved and not
just this particular scout.
And while we're on the subject, there
are very few times when you're going
to be faced with the prospect of
having to remove somebody from a unit.
A pattern of serious misbehavior
is something that you have to deal with.
Take the scout, sit down with their
parents and say: you have to correct
this behavior, otherwise he can't be
a part of our troop. Sometimes that
will fix the problem, but sometimes the
behavior goes on and then you have
to take the action that you took.
This next message- oh, we'll keep
this one anonymous too.
What do you think of a
required mock board of review for
Eagle Scout or for any advancement?
A mock board of reviews, so kind of
a court exercise or something?
A practice board of review?
Well, I don't have to go very far
to answer that question, because if you
look in the guide to advancement,
here's what you'll find.
Quote: the BSA discourages
mock or practice boards of review.
Practice
reviews may imply
that board members will ask
predetermined questions or the
board of review is anticipated to be
other than a positive experience.
Instead, the advancement
committee should aim for unrehearsed,
spontaneous answers
revealing character, citizenship
and personal fitness
at boards of review.
You'll find that under the heading
Conducting Boards of Review
and if you want the numbers on that
here they are 8.0.1.0.
I'll have a link in the podcast
notes so you can find it real easy.
Note the verbiage there.
The BSA discourages these things.
and if a troop should,
in my opinion, decide to hold practice
or mock boards of review
against the advice of the BSA,
then these cannot
be
required because that would
constitute adding to the requirements
for the rank. and under the heading
of policy on unauthorized changes
to the advancement program, which is found
right in the front
of the guide to advancement,
you'll find this statement,
quote: no council, committee, district,
unit or individual
has the authority to add to
or subtract from
advancement requirements
unquote. So those are some pretty clear
statements and this is not my
opinion. okay, It's all
very clearly worded policy
and when you sign up to be a volunteer
in the BSA,
you agree to follow all that to the letter.
If I found that my son was member of a
troop who did not follow the advice
of the BSA or required scouts
to complete unauthorized requirements,
I
would get out of there and
find another troop that gets things right.
And the third and final email
message I'm going to answer on this podcast
comes from James,
who asks: what tips do you have
for a scout master who is new
to the idea of having an active 18
to 20 year old in
an assistant scout master role?
Well, James, I was a very young
scout master at age 24-
and that was a long time
ago, over 30 years ago.
The proximity to the scouts ages
and the kind of energy I had for the work
as a young adult was different
than I have now
as an older adult or I had as a parent.
So when we're
shaping a strategy for working with
a young adult
assistant scout master, we want to
make sure we're considering that
energy and that they will have
the ability to communicate
with scouts probably a lot better than we will.
I've had the great pleasure
of having any number of
guys who were 18,, 19,, 20
sign on as assistant
scout masters and remain
fairly active for a time,
and what we did in
that case was kind of build a third layer
of leadership.
There's the youth, the young adults
and the older adults.
When I have a young adult
assistant scout master or junior
assistant scout masters, I will
train and mentor them to do
what I have done with the youth
leaders and take one more
step into the background as they
become more capable of doing it,
The goal being to let them take on
as much of my scout master
responsibilities as they would accept,
because there's a lot of fun and satisfaction in that
work and I want to share that with them.
it's not so much that I don't want
responsibility or I don't want to do the work.
do you understand what I'm saying?
Kind of creating a third level.
and when you're working with young adults,
the things they're up to at this time in life,
they're going to be around for a year or so if you're lucky,
if they're in school and they're local enough
to still participate with the troop.
well, you know, you're going to have
to have some very realistic expectations
of exactly how much time
they're going to be able to devote to all of this.
and that's a real good discussion
to have with them up front, just so everybody's
clear about exactly what your expectations are,
what their expectations are,
and then expect it to change.
because, hey, when you're in your early
20's, lots of things change, don't they?
but you never know, James, you may be working
with a future scout master there, so
keep your eyes open, Listen. if you have a
comment or a question, you want to get in touch with me.
it's pretty easy to do and I'm going to tell you how to make
that happen in just a moment.
music.
well, thank you so much for listening
to this 325th edition
of the scout master podcast.
now here's how to keep in touch.
you'll find 1600 plus articles
and over 300 editions of the podcast
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates by email.
you can keep up with us in the vast
panorama of social media
outlets. there are over 14
thousand folks who like scoutmaster blog
on facebook, where you're much more to me
than just a face in the crowd.
we have a chorus of tweeters on twitter
who type truly tremendous, thoughtful tweets.
we proffer poultry to this pictures
publicly with a parcel of
prolific printers. on pinterest,
you can watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube, but I
understand not everybody can face
facebook and some people twitter
makes them bitter. and if you've got
no interest in pinterest and you don't
put the? u in youtube, don't worry,
just zoom into the late 90s.
you can fire off a good old fashioned email.
you can always get in touch with me.
clarkgreen at
clark at scoutmastercgcom.
that's c-l-a-r-k-e
at
scoutmastercgcom
now. if all else fails.
now if all else fails,
get a bright red phone with no dial
now. this you will find
on the commissioners desk under a glass
dome. press the button on that
phone. I'll be there on the other
end to answer all your questions.
by now. it should be abundantly clear
that the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications of
anyone other than myself.
no, I am not endorsed or sponsored by
the Boy Scouts of America or any other
scouting organization for that matter.
it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scouters and perhaps
have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here he is
our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
oh, I thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.